hey Steve Oceana's former race car
driver Klaus needs fits describes the
hybrid drive porsche 918 spyder as the
fastest street-legal car anywhere they
could do everything a racing car can he
tries it out on the track in Valencia
Spain where he can push the spider to
its absolute limits
this superlative sports car equipped
with cutting-edge technology is limited
to just 918 units the hot-blooded design
easily takes the curve from the
racetrack to the city street the spider
hugs the asphalt low and wide
this a hybrid comes with three engines a
447 kilowatt rear mounted gasoline
engine and two electric motors one front
and one rear mounted it's a two-seater
with monocoque made of carbon fiber
reinforced plastic in the spirit of the
Carrera GT the Porsche 917 racer and the
RS Spyder the interior is a visual and
tactile delight with a boldly projecting
center console an instrument panel
boasting 3 gauge style displays and a
compact multifunctional steering wheel
the snug bucket seats complete the
racing cockpit feel
the large touchscreen works like a smart
phones replacing many of the traditional
switches a turn of this dial fires up
the regular engine
drivers have a variety of modes to
choose from the fully electric mode
shuts down the v8 engine completely but
what can the spider do on the racetrack
you
racing legend vault Aurora took the 918
spyder out for a spin
government after inch ladies he's never
driven a street-legal car that was so
much like a competitive model very
impressive the car roars around the
racing track as if it'd been made for it
ice pianist I forgive out
you
the 918 spyder is the first street legal
car to break the seven-minute mark for
the Nurburgring track
is a electro motor at first he could
hardly believe it but the electric
motors give the car that extra punch you
feel their incredible power the moment
you tap the accelerator powers abide to
disguise podiatrist Valda has never
experienced that with a conventional
engine and the way the combustion and
electric engines work together is
absolutely unique
our other guests testa Klaus needs fits
agrees that it's something very special
leather follows he can tell the car
delivers an extreme performance the
moment he steps on the gas it pushes him
right back into the seat and the brakes
are every bit as responsive gripping
hard and fast he took it up to 200
kilometers an hour just 7.7 seconds and
it has a sound that goes with the
performance listen he says
Oh
you
the specs show just how extreme it can
be 0 to 100 km/h in just 2.6 seconds and
burning 3.1 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers but up to 10 times that when
driven close to its top speed of 345
kilometers an hour the two electric
motors put out 210 kilowatts of power
all together with the v8 they deliver a
nice 652 kilowatts but Valle de Oro puts
the pedal to the metal he feels almost
as if he were sitting in a space shuttle
he tried a racing start the day before
and he says he came very close to
blacking out your average driver could
hardly even imagine anything like this
he adds respectfully on the green say
the six efficient breakout become a
novice is a spoon fastball fillable
mention the contact is gonna cost it
catch the Porsche 918 spyder if you can
this is your speed freaks new dream car
those with my father close needs fits
admits that nobody actually needs a car
like this but he'd still like to have
one and he doesn't think he's alone in
that opinion celina